So we've heard about the new exciting drugs, and now we're going to go back in time and talk about autologous stem cell transplants, and is there still a role, or is it dead?
So looking historically at previous studies, you can look at these curves and say, yeah, they look similar shapes to all the curves we've seen in the prior talks.
The difference is the x-axis is in years, not in months.
You can see median progression-free survival following autologous stem cell transplant of almost a decade in multiple studies,
and then subsequently the benefit of maintenance rituximab was established in the LEMA study with a seven-year progression-free survival of 79% in the group that received rituximab maintenance.
These are three studies of real-world data.
What's striking in these studies is that less than half of the patients,
and the first two studies who were eligible for autologous transplant actually underwent autologous transplant.
The first column is the MCL consortium, all academic centers, about a little over 500 patients.
Only a third actually went transplant, and they showed that transplant was a significant predictor of outcome,
and the top curve in purple is the patient group that received a citerabine induction.
The middle column is the flat iron database.
Predominantly community centers, over 3,000 patients.
In that study, only 25% of eligible patients underwent transplant,
and the median overall survival was similar in both groups,
and the time to next treatment also showed no advantage with autologous stem cell transplant.
The last column is 25 centers, predominantly academic, higher number of patients undergoing transplant at 67% of eligible patients,
and they showed that transplant was a significant predictor of outcome, and the time to next treatment also showed no advantage with autologous stem cell transplant.
and they showed that transplant was a significant predictor of outcome,
and the time to next treatment also showed no advantage with autologous stem cell transplant.
The last column is 25 centers, predominantly academic, higher number of patients undergoing transplant at 67% of eligible patients,
and they showed that transplant was associated with a progression-free survival benefit, but not overall survival.
Then we get to some more modern studies.
The ECOG study looked at do all patients need autologous stem cell transplant.
Most of us are probably familiar with this study.
Patients received an induction regimen of the physician's choice,
and then at the end of study, they had an MRD assessment in the peripheral blood.
If they were MRD positive or indeterminate,
if they were MRD positive or indeterminate,
if they were MRD negative,
they were randomized to transplant versus no transplant.
The first curve shows arm A versus arm B,
and you can see that the lines are superimposable,
showing that there was no benefit, at least in the short term,
at three years for patients undergoing transplant if they were MRD negative.
This was presented as a late-breaking abstract last in 2024 at ASH.
In the subsequent patients who were MRD positive or MRD indeterminate,
they underwent transplant, and their three-year progression-free survival was about 75%.
The TRIANGLE study also looked at can we replace autologous stem cell transplant with a BTK inhibitor.
So it was a three-arm study.
Induction was RCHOP alternating with RDHAP.
In arm one, it was standard of care, RCHOP alternating with RDHAP,
for a total of six cycles, followed by autologous stem cell transplant,
and then observation.
Arm two added ibrutinib to the RCHOP arm and still received transplant,
followed then by two years of ibrutinib maintenance.
And then the bottom arm added ibrutinib,
but took out transplant and then still had two years of ibrutinib maintenance.
What the study showed is that autologous transplant plus ibrutinib
was superior to autologous transplant only.
Autologous transplant plus ibrutinib was not superior to ibrutinib without transplant.
Autologous transplant is not superior to ibrutinib.
And ibrutinib without transplant was superior to autologous transplant.
And then the curve at the bottom right in red,
there was a superior overall survival with autologous transplant plus ibrutinib,
or ibrutinib alone, compared with transplant.
So both ibrutinib-containing arms were better than transplant.
The study was subsequently amended about halfway through
to add in maintenance for teximab,
and about half the patients received maintenance for teximab.
Does anyone benefit from autologous transplant in the triangle study?
Although this was non-statistical benefit,
you can see that the curves that added in transplant to the ibrutinib
did have a higher PFS curve in both the KI-67 as well as the P53-positive,
a little bit less than the blastoid variant.
This is our Mayo Clinic data of over 25 years,
looking at 303 patients who underwent transplant.
Again, obviously, slope to the curve here, no plateau,
but you can see that the x-axis is going out to 20 years.
So the median follow-up was 11.2 years,
and the median follow-up was 11.2 years,
and our median progression-free survival was just under a decade.
Looking at the high-risk patients, they had a shorter PFS,
but even if they only had one high-risk factor,
the median progression-free survival was still 7.7 years.
So these are still very durable remissions,
even though they're not curative.
TP53 mutated mantle cell lymphoma does not benefit from autologous transplant.
So that group,
which is typically not taken to transplant.
This was recently presented at EBMT,
and if we just focus on the top half of the slide,
you can see their approach.
So if you have access to BTK in the first line in high-risk,
they still recommend autologous transplant.
In the standard risk, transplant is not done.
If you don't have access to a BTK in either high-risk or standard risk,
the plan is still to go to autologous transplant,
and they have not incorporated the MRD data into their approach.
This is kind of taking all of the studies and creating a hybrid approach.
So we have the ECOG approach,
which is just based on MRD on the left-hand side.
We have the triangle approach with the BTK,
with the alternating ARCHOP and RRD-HAP not incorporating transplant.
Although I question,
could you still consider it for the high-risk patients and perhaps maybe
incorporate the MRD?
And then it comes to the hybrid approach,
which basically induction chemotherapy of your choice,
typically more of a BR-based regimen,
plus or minus a BTK,
but in the MRD-guided transplant,
if undetectable MRD,
no transplant,
if still detectable,
then perhaps consider a transplant and then add rituximab and BTK maintenance
at the end.
And thank you.